Joan Celia Lee, who often goes by JC Lee,
the daughter of the late, great Marvel mastermind
Stan Lee, had some biting words for Marvel
Studios parent company Disney after it failed
to reach an agreement with Sony Pictures to
keep Spider-Man in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Lee spoke with TMZ about the situation, and
it's clear that she's not happy over what
she perceives to be a Disney power play to
score full control of Marvel Comics' flagship
character, whom Stan Lee co-created with Steve
Ditko, and for whom Sony has long held the
film rights.
She said:
"Marvel and Disney seeking total control of
my father's creations must be checked and
balanced by others who, while still seeking
to profit, have genuine respect for Stan Lee
and his legacy.
Whether it's Sony or someone else's, the continued
evolution of Stan's characters and his legacy
deserves multiple points of view."
Lee then went from implying Marvel Studios
did not have respect for Stan the Man's legacy
to outright stating it.
"When my father died, no one from Marvel or
Disney reached out to me.
From day one, they have commoditized my father's
work and never shown him or his legacy any
respect or decency…
In the end, no one could have treated my father
worse than Marvel and Disney's executives."
That's a brutal assessment, and, frankly,
confusing, considering that Stan Lee made
cameos in every single Marvel Studios film
up until his death.
Publicly, Marvel head honcho Kevin Feige has
never shown anything but respect for Lee and
his legacy.
After the icon's death last year, Feige said
in a statement,
"He was very special, and I've always said,
anybody who met Stan…I've never heard one
story of somebody meeting Stan and not being
overwhelmed with excitement.
He never disappointed, and I was lucky enough
to see him about 10 days before he passed
away… it doesn't seem like he's gone.
Because just like with Walt Disney on this
lot, his influence will never go away."
JC Lee's comments came the same week as a
Sony Pictures statement which painted the
decision to axe the wall-crawler from the
MCU as one which ultimately was made by Marvel.
It read:
"We are disappointed, but respect Disney's
decision not to have [Feige] continue as a
lead producer of our next live-action Spider-Man
film.
We hope this might change in the future, but
understand that the many new responsibilities
that Disney has given him - including all
their newly added Marvel properties - do not
allow time for him to work on IP they do not
own,"
Inside sources, meanwhile, have insisted that
the split is solely over money, with Disney
having sought a bigger piece of the Spider-Pie
going forward.
"Not get outta here."
"100 bucks?
The ad said 3,000."
This struggle over Spider-Man is likely far
from over.
The reported split between the two studios
- which reached their initial agreement to
share custody of Spidey in 2015 - caused a
massive outcry among fans, most of whom were
far more pleased with the MCU iteration of
the character portrayed by Tom Holland than
they had been with the Amazing Spider-Man
franchise, which was considered a commercial
and critical failure.
"Ho ho ho!
Well, look who's here!
Spidey!
How was your morning?
Aces, Max.
Aces."
Of course, the failure of the two studios
to reach an agreement isn't final.
The 2015 deal was struck after talks between
Sony and Marvel similarly fell apart in 2014,
a situation that came to light when a series
of internal emails among Sony execs were made
public, and the strong reaction from fans
was undoubtedly a factor which brought the
parties back to the table.
Sony maintains that it fully intends to produce
at least two more Spider-Man solo films starring
Holland, with Spider-Man: Homecoming and Spider-Man:
Far From Home director Jon Watts also returning.
These films would presumably take place in
the Sony Universe of Marvel Characters, which
includes Venom.
That would mean the wholesale porting of a
character from one shared universe to another,
totally unrelated one.
This has never happened before, in live action
anyway, and it would obviously present some
narrative challenges.
To craft a satisfactory narrative around how
in the heck Spider-Man zapped to another universe,
the two studios may have to cooperate, at
least very briefly.
Perhaps prominent voices like Lee's can prod
the two companies to come back to the bargaining
table, because splitting may be more of a
headache than it's worth.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.